[Music]  we're eternals  we came here 7000 years ago  to protect humans from the deviants  now they're back  on november 5th it's time  you can't protect them  this is what the end of the world looks  like at least we have front row seats  you know what's never saved the planet  you're sarcasm  marvel studios eternal sweet pg-13 get  tickets now  [Music]  mr  [Music]  we're eternals  7 000 years we've protected humans from  the demons  why didn't you guys help fight thanos or  any war all the other terrible things  throughout history  we were instructed not to interfere  until now  you hear that eternal's assembled  hi  hello hey who's your gardener  this planet and these people have  changed all of us  when you love something  you protect it  for eternity  [Music]  marvel studios eternals what's your  superpower  you know that your babysitting  privileges are completely revoked  pg-13 get tickets now  you